It is considered a little bit more realistic problem. Imagine that you were to
hire a robot, and a task of the robot was to paint the ceiling in your room, and
also paint the ladder. So, two goals here,
paint the ladder paint the ceiling and note that the two goals are in conflict.
Because if the robot paints the ladder first, the ladder will become wet.
And this robot cannot climb on it, in order to paint the ceiling. So, the robot
must really first paint the ceiling, then climb down, then paint the ladder and
everything is okay. You would expect a human to get this almost immediately,
you probably got it almost immediately. You have to paint the ceiling first,
before you paint the ladder. Of course, every time I've hired construction
workers, they always paint the ladder first. Then they go and take a break, and
so that I had to pay them anyway. We'll accept that kind of behavior from human
construction workers, we would not accept that from robot construction workers.
The robots must be intelligent, they must know how to prioritize the goals.
Well, in order to reason about these goals, the robot first must be able to
represent them. So, how can we present the goal of painted ceiling? Now that we
have learned about propositional logic, here is a preposition that can
represent painted ceiling. This is the object, this is the predicate on that.